und schon wieder das ist wirklich der
hammer immer wieder werden neue schwarze
löcher entdeckt und immer wieder gibt es
neue hinweise auf noch mehr schwarze
löcher müssen wir jetzt wirklich langsam
die theorie der dunkle materie über den
haufen werfen sind die schwarzen löcher
einfach die triebfeder von allem im
universum
ja es liegt nahe jetzt den klicks 1
infektion herzlich willkommen
also jetzt mal ganz konzentriert wenn
ich mir so ansehe wie oft ich in letzter
zeit videos über schwarze löcher und
ihre bedeutung gemacht habe wahnsinn
und wenn ich das alles mal so
zusammenfassen dann ist das wirklich
ziemlich beeindruckend jedes mal kommen
da raus es sind mehr sie spielen eine
größere rolle und es gibt theorien die
sagen dass sie die dunkle materie sind
aber erstmal eine aktuelle studie es
wurden in der vergangenheit ja schon
ziemlich gigantische schwarze löcher
gefunden die ohne galaxie wo wir
eigentlich im zentrum seien müssten
durch das all fliegen es wird vermutet
dass sie bei kollisionen von galaxien
ins all geschleudert worden jetzt hat
aber eine forschungsgruppe hinweise auf
zusätzliche supermassereiche schwarze
löcher in den außenbereichen von
galaxien gefunden michael tremmel von
der yale university in den usa hat mit
seinem team jedenfalls einen auf
galaxienentstehung spezialisiertes
programm simulationen erstellen lassen
und das ergebnis sind zusätzliche
supermassereiche schwarze löcher die
befinden sich in der halo also dem
außenbereich von galaxien ursache sind
wohl die kollisionen von galaxien
miteinander nach denen diese
supermassereichen schwarzen löcher eben
nicht in das zentrum der neuen zusammen
gebildeten galaxie gestürzt sind sondern
eben im außenbereich geblieben sind im
gegensatz zum normalfall zitat es kann
aber auch vorkommen dass dieser prozess
stoppt und die supermassereichen
schwarzen löcher das galaktische zentrum
gar nicht erreichen so das
forschungsteam also der prozess des ins
zentrum stürzen der wird dann gestoppt
und das forschungs 7 hat auch
ausgerechnet wie viele dieser
supermassereichen schwarzen löcher sich
im außenbereich einer galaxie befinden
es sind mehr als 4 supermassereiche
schwarze löcher also insgesamt
gibt es demnach im universum fünfmal
mehr supermassereiche schwarze löcher
mit millionen und milliarden
sonnenmassen als bisher angenommen und
das ist nicht das erste mal dass
zusätzliche schwarze löcher entdeckt
werden er ist letztlich wurde er
festgestellt dass es viel mehr riesige
sterne gibt als bisher angenommen
untersuchungsobjekt war die magellansche
wolke im dortigen stern bildungssektor
30 dorados gibt es tausendmal mehr
sonnenmassen die dort pro jahr entstehen
und was da entsteht ist absolut
spektakulär und wirft alles um denn es
werden dort vielmehr große massereiche
sterne produziert als eigentlich bisher
angenommen und das ist wirklich
frappierend zitat wir waren enorm
überrascht als wir feststellten dass 30
uhr asus so viel mehr massereiche sterne
gebildet hat als erwartet so erst autor
fabian schneider von der oxford
university
sie sind zwar immer noch seltener als
kleinere sterne wie unsere sonne
aber sie machen einen deutlich größeren
anteil am gesamtgewicht aus weil sie so
viel schwerer sind ein beispiel ist
r136a1 der blaue riese der wird auf 300
sonnenmassen geschätzt und leuchtet
achtung 8,7 millionen mal heller als die
sonne waren sind zitat unsere ergebnisse
legen nahe dass der größte anteil der
gesamten stern maxe nicht im massearmen
sternen steckt erklärt mitautor chris
evans vom royal observatorien edinburgh
die ergebnisse sind absolut umwerfend
sie bedeuten dass es rund 70 prozent
mehr supernovae gibt als bisher
angenommen und weiter aus diesen
riesenstern entstehen mehr und größere
schwarze löcher da viele dieser
riesensterne zu schwarzen löchern
zusammenhang vermuten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
dass und jetzt bitte hinsetzen es
dreimal so viele schwarze löcher gibt
als bisher gedacht
also immer mehr und auch immer mehr und
größere schwarze löcher die gefunden
werden und da bin ich wieder bei meiner
lieblings theorie was wäre wenn der
hauptbestandteil des weltalls schwarze
löcher wären also masse mäßig dann gäbe
es keine dunkle materie und die
schwarzen löcher müssten die fehlende
masse darstellen weswegen die dunkle
materie
vermutet wird warum das ist ganz simpel
womit wir dabei wären das plötzlich
alles ganz einfach wäre die dunkle
materie ist ja vermutet und noch nicht
bewiesen mit ihrer gravitation dafür
verantwortlich dass sich galaxien anders
verhalten als sie würden wenn sie nur
aus materie bestehen würden also
sichtbarer materie die sternsysteme am
äußeren rand bewegen sich viel schneller
als erwartet also wenn nur die sichtbare
materie vorhanden wäre aber genau dieses
verhalten könnten ebenso schwarze löcher
verursachen sie kennen wir schon
und wir wissen sehr genau was sie
verursachen nämlich genau das und wenn
man sich auf wikipedia den ersten satz
zur aktuellen beschreibung der dunkle
materie ansieht dann ist das eine
absolute erleuchtung dunkle materie ist
eine postulierte form von materie die
nicht direkt sichtbar ist aber über die
gravitation wechsel wird und auf was
trifft genau diese beschreibung zu exakt
auf schwarze löcher
das würde auch erklären warum die
seltsamen teilchen der dunklen materie
nie gefunden wurden und es gibt eine
wissenschaftliche arbeit dazu alexander
kaczynski vom goddard space flight
center der nasa hat dazu eine studie
veröffentlicht und die ist simpel und
einfach mind blowing seine these zuerst
sind in unserem universum die schwarzen
löcher entstanden sogenannte primor die
aale schwarze löcher
sie bilden die dunkle materie und haben
überhaupt dafür gesorgt dass die materie
die nicht in sie gestürzt ist sterne
sternsysteme und galaxien bilden konnte
sie war nämlich eigentlich zu heiß dafür
die schwarzen löcher haben sie durch
ihre gravitation erst so komprimiert
dass sie gestirnen bilden konnte zitat
diese studie macht sich zum anliegen
verschiedene ideen und beobachtungen
zusammen zu bringen und zu untersuchen
wie gut sie zusammenpassen und sie
passen überraschend gut sagt kaschins
trieb wenn das alles korrekt ist dann
sind alle galaxien eingeschossen unsere
eigenen in eine gewaltige sphäre von
schwarzen löchern eingebettet von denen
jedes rund 30 mal massereicher ist als
die sonne die coolsten schwarzen löcher
und die durch das verschmelzen von
schwarzen löchern entstanden sind haben
dann materie um sich gesammelt und so
die galaxien gebildet und diese sphäre
von schwarzen löchern
die scheint jetzt stück für stück
entdeckt zu werden wenn ihr als erstes
neues zu diesem thema so schwarze löcher
und dunkle materie und zu allen anderen
themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine
telefonnummer ihr whats app dann erfahrt
ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom
neuesten video täglich garantiert und
für jeden der drauf klickt gibt es in
der begrüßungs nachricht ein kleines
cooles cody einfach hier draufklicken
und gut durchlesen und natürlich nicht
das aber mit der genau glocker vergessen
hier geht es weiter also hier dafür auch
draufklicken klicken die geschichte des
universums muss umgeschrieben werden
da geht es auch um dieses thema etwas
ausführlicher ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran